My CBC came back with hemoglobin, a little low, 11.5, and hematocrit, 35.5, which is low.
And my lymph percentage was slightly high.
My white blood cell codes are 6, and red blood cell code is 3.89, which is low.
I do feel a tiny bit fatigued lately.
Could I be fighting something off?
I will have a cup of heads of blood draw, a lab draw on Friday.
This was just a lab so I had colleges to run.
Okay, with a CBC done at your hemoglobin is a little bit low.
Your hematocrit is a little bit low.
I don't know about your other blood markers.
Your red cell width, your other markers that would give you that type of edemia.
But this is suggested of edemia right there.
And edemia is going to either be an iron deficiency edemia, which is the most common.
Or a B12 edemia, which is still very common, a B6 edemia.
So there's different types of edemia that could be causing the most commonly.
It's going to be an iron deficiency edemia.
And then do you got a dig into why is that?
Do I have a bleeding? Do I have a history of blood loss?
And I'm just recovering. I had surgery and I'm recovering from that.
Or I have, this was right at my period time.
And I have really heavy periods.
Or do I have an ulcer? Do I, you have to investigate why?
Or you know, it's because a person has cancer and their cancer is feed up.
It's all different types of reason why.
And then your white blood cell code is six.
That's not really high.
So even though your lymphocyte percentage was elevated,
could you have a little bit of a virus?
Maybe, yeah, especially if your last white blood cell code was 4.5.
And now this went up to six.
Sure, you could be fighting a little bug.
I certainly wouldn't with fatigue.
I certainly wouldn't rule out the edemia.
So look at your blood work again and see what that looks like would be the right things to do.
One of those blood tests in the CBC or CMT are those blood tests.
The ones I talked about with your liver would be in the CMT.
So the, a CMP actually.
So CBC is going to measure your red blood cell, white blood cell.
And then the differential B is breaks out your white blood cells into lymphocytes,
neutrophils, blah, blah, blah.
And then a more of an edemia panel, which is a more complete CBC is going to measure other things like your read cell volume.
And your main platelet volume, your red cell width and things like that.
So that's going to give you a differential based upon other red blood cell factors to know if a person has anemia to know what type of anemia.
Your complete metabolic panel is going to look at all your like electrolytes, calcium, potassium, sodium, and then a complete metabolic pedal is going to include your liver panel.
So there's different labs that call these things different names, but CBC and complete metabolic pedal are standard.
There's a lot of places you'll go and you'll say, I want a complete metabolic pedal and they'll do a simplified metabolic pedal and they won't do the liver tests, which is just very frustrating because quite honestly, it's not really literally only costs $20 to do complete liver panel.
You just don't understand why they truncate these labs if they're really trying to find out what's going on with the patient and your blasted insurance covers it.
Good to say, why don't you notice many tests what you're going to take blood out of that person's arm as you possibly can to get to a proper differential diagnosed figure what's going on with the patient.
It just blows my mind sometimes, but such is life.
So sometimes you have to take control and you have to ask for things, so just ask for those things.
And I did a cast on a pack for an hour still, if you had that much paid doing it for an hour, I would really start just doing it a couple of minutes.
So again, you don't want to aggravate things, you want to make things worse, just start slow and let it bother me at all and maybe tomorrow do it five minutes.
So let it bother me at all and the next day do it maybe 10 minutes, let's go slow like that.